before we go into the details of the of
the Cuban Missile Crisis it's important
to understand the world's environment
entering into October of 1962 in 1959
you have a revolution in Cuba led by
Fidel Castro and he is heading the
Communist Party there Cuba is now a
communist nation right off of the coast
of the United States the this is the
middle of the of the Cold War the United
States believes in a strategy of
containment does not like this so in
1961 the United States the CIA the CAD
meanest the Kennedy administration they
try using Cuban exiles people who have
left Cuba they they try to support them
to enter and invade Cuba at the Bay of
Pigs
but the whole the whole effort wasn't
planned properly the support for the
Cuban exiles the counter revolutionaries
those that were trying to oust Castro it
was kind of this this half-hearted
effort and it was this big failure so
the Bay of Pigs invasion was a failure
in 1961 and it made John F Kennedy seem
a little bit weak it made the CIA seem
it didn't make anyone on the American
side look all that competent because of
that failure on top of that we're in the
middle of the Cold War remember this and
at the same time if you go to if you go
to what the US was doing around the
Soviet Union it started it started
placing missiles starting in the late
50s all the way into 1961 and 1962 it
started placing medium-range ballistic
missiles in Turkey and in Italy these
are where they were located and the
significance of that is that now these
missiles could reach the major
population centers of the Soviet Union
in really a matter of minutes in 10 to
20 minutes I think 16 minutes was how
long most of these stay airborne and
when in a situation where both sides
have nuclear weapons there was this kind
of notion of well maybe if you're able
to get to the other guy faster they
wouldn't be able to retaliate and maybe
you wouldn't have that mutually assured
destruction so there's this whole idea
that you want to get your missiles as
close as possible so that they could
reach the population centers the
strategic centers of your opponent as
quickly as possible and if you look up
on the web you can actually
find the actual missile sites and when
they were installed and when they became
operational these are the ones that were
in Italy kind of right here near the
heel near the heel of Italy so you have
this environment the United States was
looking a little bit weak after the Bay
of Pigs invasion it looks like they
wanted to oust Castro but they were they
did it slightly or they weren't able to
do it and they did they weren't able
because they were slightly inept at the
same time you could imagine that the
Soviet Union did not appreciate the
United States placing placing these
missiles so close to its population
centers missiles that could reach its
population centers very easily so now we
fast forward to October of 1962 and the
entire Cuban Missile Crisis will occur
over 13 or 14 days during night October
of 1962 so on the 14th of October we're
sending these you to spy planes over
Cuba so this right here is a u-2 spy
plane that is a u-2 spy plane and it
takes pictures that look like this and
then the next day on October 15th you
have the CIA analyst and they're saying
wow you know that that that looks like
missiles over there this looks like
ballistic missiles that are being set up
that are being set up in Cuba and so all
of a sudden it looks like the Soviet
Union is using Cuba to do the same thing
that we use turkey in Italy for to set
up ballistic missiles really right off
of our coast and ballistic missiles that
could now that can now reach any of the
strategic population centers especially
on the East Coast or the Midwest of the
United States so by the 16th so this is
literally two days after the pictures
were taken the next day they're
analyzing them they tell the State
Department about them the 16th they tell
Kennedy about them and Kennedy holds a
meeting of the executive committee and
it wasn't called XCOM just that but it
was really a subset of special advisers
a subset of the National Security
Council and other advisers that
essentially become the brain trust to
figure out what to do about this forming
crisis because all of a sudden you have
a state that we don't like off of our
borders a communist state a state
aligned with the Soviet Union all of a
sudden it has nuclear missiles it looks
like these are
offensive weapons these are weapons
being designed for first-strike
capability once again if they're being
launched from Cuba maybe they can attack
maybe they can obliterate the US before
the US even has an opportunity to
respond properly so this really freaks
out the Kennedy administration on the
and so they start to think about what
can they what can they do about it and
early on you know there's a couple you
could just kind of call and talk to the
Soviets about and say hey we don't like
that why don't you why don't you undo
your missiles but they didn't really
think that that would have any
significant effect on the Soviets
especially because they probably thought
that Kennedy was weak at this port point
and just to understand who was leading
the Soviets at this time it was
Khrushchev this is Khrushchev right over
here and he had even made remarks to the
effect that he thought that Kennedy was
young and maybe naive and maybe too
intellectual to really play a good a
good game of chicken here and so the
u.s. kind of felt that it had to look
strong here and so the only the real
options on the table were maybe blockade
Cuba and so a blockade could be an
all-out blockade so it would be an
economic blockade but that's actually
considered an act of war because you're
to a large degree starving a country
another opera another option for the
United States because it was commit was
completely viewed as unacceptable that
these missiles should be here and that
they should be deployable from Cuba the
other option would be to do air attacks
on on these these these missile silos
and then the other you know kind of the
most extreme the most extreme action
would be to actually invade Cuba and
obviously that goes in line with kind of
the USA's general interest of not having
a communist regime so close to its own
borders so this is what what Kennedy and
his team was was wrestling with and
really early on and really early on in
these early days most of the team was
actually advising Kennedy that they
should do a full-scale invasion of Cuba
that they thought this was the only
thing that the Soviets would take
seriously it would show that that the
u.s. is serious about this and and they
didn't think that the Soviet Union would
really try to put up a fight in Cuba so
far away from their own borders but
Kennedy probably pretty thinking about
it pretty reasonably realized well you
know hey they might not do anything in
Cuba and they might allow us to oust
Castro
and install a new regime there but they
might retaliate in fact they probably
would retaliate in Europe and
specifically in Berlin probably in in
Germany as a whole so just just for the
sake of getting these things out of Cuba
we could sacrifice a lot in in in Europe
and even more the any type of conflict
between the US and the Soviet Union
could easily escalate to a nuclear war
so these were all on the table the u.s.
goes on high alert it prepares for any
of these situations because they really
don't know what's going to happen you
know the the army the Air Force and the
Navy starts mobilizing so on kind of you
know with hours notice any of those
options can kind of go into effect by
the 22nd you have the executive
committee and that just becomes formula
formalized as an actual official group
that is advising the president in this
capacity and on the 22nd Kennedy finally
puts out his first salvo on what what is
the USS position on what's going on here
and before this and just to make make
things clear on the 18th he did meet he
did meet with the Minister of Foreign
Affairs the Soviet Minister of Foreign
Affairs and Ray go meet Gromyko and I'm
sure I'm butchering the pronunciations
and this is where the first time that
Kennedy's like hey you got these
offensive weapons and grim echoes
insisting that no they're just defensive
weapons and to most people defensive
weapons would mean things like
surface-to-air missiles things that
would stop planes from bombings but not
surface-to-surface missiles not
something that could attack a country
but we'll see in future letters from
Khrushchev that maybe they actually did
perceive these these missiles as somehow
being defensive
but you fast forward that was on the
18th it kind of made the Amade kennedy
and the u.s. frustrated with the
Russians because it felt like you know
the Americans are saying look we clearly
know you have missiles there but Gromyko
saying no these are just offensive
weapons nothing to worry about why
you're taking this so seriously the 19th
US goes on high alert it starts thinking
about all of these options the 22nd this
committee is formed formally but more
importantly Kennedy gives a a speech to
state the United States opinion and I'll
just read it right here to halt this
offensive build-up a strict quarantine
on all offensive military equipment
under
shipment to Cuba is being initiated all
ships of any kind bound for Cuba for
whatever nation from whatever nation or
port will if found contain if found to
contain cargoes of offensive weapons be
turned back this quarantine will be
extended if needed to other types of
cargo and carriers we are not at this
time however denying the necessities of
life as the Soviets attempted to do in
their Berlin Blockade of 1948 so the the
Kennedy the Kennedy administration's
position became slightly more nuanced
they said we can't do a an all-out
blockade one that is an act of war -
that is to large degree inhumane why
should we starve the Cuban people what
we're going to do is kind of a a filter
on the cargo going into Cuba we will
only stop we will only inspect things
that we we suspect are holding armaments
and we will only turn back the ships
that are actually doing it but then on
the 24th there is a cable from
Khrushchev and it says if you cool away
the situation which has developed not
giving way to passions you will
understand that the Soviet Union cannot
fail to reject the arbitrary demands of
the United States and that the Soviet
Union views the blockade as an act of
aggression and that their ships will be
instructed to ignore it so there the
game of chicken is beginning to emerge
the United States is saying look this is
unacceptable we're going to stop you
from shipping arms to Cuba the on the
24th Christians saying who are you to
tell us what to do and you know there's
this kind of undercurrent of like wait
you you've already got stuff set up in
Italy and Turkey not too far from us
what how can you dare you know and they
call it a blockade even though the u.s.
is calling it a quarantine this is an
act of aggression and we will ignore it
so both parties are kind of saying we
don't care what you're going to do we're
going to do what whatever we have to do
and this whole time I mean both sides
are getting tensed the whole world is
kind of taking sides you're making
public statements about what's right or
wrong so it we really are getting very
close to the brink of a very major
confrontation between the Soviet Union
and the United States and there's a you
know you can read the book thirteen days
Robert Kennedy there's also the movie
thirteen days which actually is not
based on the book but both of them
really kind of give the account of what
happened over this period but then you
fast-forward
25th and Kennedy essentially replies
that look these are offensive weapons
and these require the responses I have
announced I hope that your government
will take necessary action to permit
restoration of the earlier situation so
Kenny saying look we have to do this
these are offensive weapons we cannot
tolerate these weapons so close to us to
US borders and so also on the 25th the
quarantines in effect it does get
challenged the u.s. does start to
inspect some ships they tried to inspect
one ship that got away a little bit and
the Soviets did so the Soviets even
though they're there they're speaking
the game of chicken they they are
turning back they did turn back 14 ships
and the best guess is that those 14
ships probably did contain some type of
armament so even though publicly
everyone is playing a very strong game
behind the scenes there is a little bit
of a softening of the stance and then
you fast forward to the 26th and
Khrushchev essentially sends his first
his first proposal and it's interesting
here because from in Khrushchev's mind
and this is a fascinating letter read
it's a fairly long letter so I'm not
going to go into the whole thing and you
can get it at this URL right over here
it's a fascinating letter I may be able
to a whole video where I just read this
letter he kind of he kind of goes into
the nuance of what he views as a
defensive or an offensive weapons he
admits he implicitly admits that they
have these that the missiles are there
that they're not these benign weapons
but he in his letter he kind of makes a
nuance that he views them as defensive
weapons he says look you guys in Veit
you guys attempted to oust Castro
already we view Castro as an ally we
think that by placing these weapons here
it you will be less likely to be able to
ask Castro because you will be afraid of
these weapons so Khrushchev is kind of
setting up we don't have you know
Christian saying we don't have any
intention of using these to attack you
for no reason we're just putting these
here to essentially defend one of our
allies so he's saying that's the reason
that's the reason that they place those
weapons there in the first place kind of
saying look you did Bay of Pigs you were
the ones that took the first shot now we
are defending it that might have been
the rationale another rationale for why
they did it is just and probably the
more strategic rationale is that we
already did have these missiles that
were pointed at the Soviet Union in
Turkey and
and the Soviet Union just wanted to have
parity so they wanted to put missiles on
and near the US on some allies country
from the Soviet Union's point of view so
on the 26th Khrushchev's first proposal
that was given through a cable says if
assurances were given by the President
and the government of the United States
that the USA itself would not
participate so assurances assurances let
me underline this in a different color
assurance is that the USA itself would
not participate in an attack on Cuba and
would restrain other others from actions
of this sort probably the Cuban exiles
if you would recall your fleet this
would immediately change everything I am
NOT speaking for Fidel Castro but I
think that he and the government of Cuba
evidently would declare demobilization
and would appeal to the people to get
down to peaceful labor then to the
question you know the end of the the
Communists always like talking about
labor then to the question of armaments
would disappear since there's since if
there is no threat then armaments are a
burden for every people so in this first
proposal that came over a cable he's
essentially saying look if you guys just
promise not to attack Cuba if you just
make assurances that you will not attack
Cuba then we'll essentially undo
everything will will go will will give
in to your wishes and you know this
stance right here really does make it
look like their main interest in having
those missiles was kind of to protect
Cuba kind so that the US would not try
to oust the Communists from there but
then on the next day Khrushchev has a
broadcast a public broadcast where he
kind of changes his tone a little bit
now he's saying that they would undo the
situation in Cuba only if the United
States removed their missiles from Italy
and Turkey so he's sending a little
mixed messages his first message was
kind of a softer stance look you just
you guys just promised not to invade
Cuba
and we're going to pull out of Cuba the
second the second stance is saying no no
no we're willing to take our missiles
out of Cuba if you take your missiles
out of Italy and Turkey and on the same
day a you to another you to spy plane
gets shot down over Cuba and this is
when both armies are really it kind of
you know they're like hair-trigger
notice so it's really scary situation
and this was actually done by it was a
local decision by a
a Soviet commander and and Khrushchev
actually did not want this to happen and
lucky for lucky for I guess the world
the the the u.s. did not use this alone
as a reason to engage in war they said
maybe it's an accident if this happens
again then we'll use it as war so it was
lucky that this did not trigger an
immediate war with the with the Soviets
but but the Kennedy administration still
had the question which of these was the
more serious you know which which of
these which of these requests were the
Soviets really making this is a more
significant request are they requesting
for both and so it was eventually
decided on the 27th that hey let's just
pretend like we didn't even know that
the Americans didn't even know about the
second request that asks for more and
let's just reply to this first request
so you essentially have Kennedy agreeing
to Khrushchev and saying okay we'll do
your first request we will agree not to
invade Cuba
if you remove if you remove your
missiles and then essentially what
happens and you know that puts a
Khrushchev in a weird situation because
this is something that he did recommend
but they were ignoring this over here
but through backchannels we said we will
officially agree to this but through
backchannels the kennedy administration
said and we would also be on an
understanding we would also have an
understanding on the missiles in Italy
and Turkey that look you know this isn't
part of the deal but we see what you're
saying and we're probably we're probably
going to remove them and what the
Soviets also didn't know at that time is
that the that the Americans were
planning on that these these missiles to
a large degree by this point in time
we're already obsolete because we
already had Polaris missiles that were
deployable by submarines and clearly
submarines can deploy things much closer
to the action and they're much harder to
track you can't surveil them in all the
rest so the u.s. kind of agreed to it
but they did it secretly and the whole
point here is that neither side wanted
to look like they're giving in neither
side wanted to look weak but on the 28th
there was finally an agreement and so
publicly the first the first Khrushchev
proposal was agreed to by both
Khrushchev and the United States
Khrushchev agreed to remove to not send
any more weapons and also dismantle the
weapons that were there and the
Americans agreed that they would not
that they would not invade Cuba and so
you can imagine the big win
here the big winner here is probably
Fidel Castro because the whole time he's
paranoid that the u.s. is planning
another attack on him at least publicly
now they saying that they cannot invade
and if they did it would look like
they're going back on their word and
privately privately the u.s. agreed to
remove its missiles from Turkey and
Italy they didn't want to do this
publicly because then it would look like
they're being weak then it would look
like the the Soviets were able to do
this aggression aggressive action and by
doing it they were able to extract
something out of the United States which
is actually the reality they were able
to by doing this action they were able
to get these missiles removed from
Turkey in Italy but the United States
wanted to look strong the Kennedy has
well there's always an approaching
election he had especially after the Bay
of Pigs he need to look like a strong
leader and so to some degree you have to
give Khrushchev credit for this he kind
of swallowed his pride and allowed it to
publicly look like he lost in the
negotiation he publicly made it look
like he got nothing in return for
backing down but in reality he did he
just didn't necessarily get credit for
it but this was a big deal because this
was the closest that the Soviet Union
and the and and the u.s. ever got to
really the brink during the Cold War